dans cette ruelle comme ailleurs à
montréal tout est calme il n'y a que ce
chat que naomi son père qui accroche des
dessins d'arc en ciel pour donner un
courage aux personnes quand il passe qui
s en vont bien aller pendant la
l'épidémie pi2 pas trop s'inquiéter pour
mais omis la dernière semaine a été
difficile
ce qu'elle entend ce qu'elle voit sur le
virus le préoccupe
chaput stressé parce que ça me tente
vraiment pas de l'avoir raf elle aussi
est inquiet mois jaquette parce que mon
père est asthmatique
c'est vrai j'ai parlé fois que ça se
propage la famille qu'elle attrape
essentielle pour assurer les enfants le
ministre québécois de la famille a tenu
un point de presse virtuelle il a
répondu une quinzaine de questions
d'enfants de partout au québec
il en avait reçu plus de 1000 si jamais
premier ministre à trappes lakovic 19
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
est ce que le virus pourrait piquer les
légumes ou les fruits les aliments et m6
on les mange et ce compris la trappe et
des questions et des réponses que
raphaël antoine et leur mère ont écouté
avec beaucoup d'attention le virus se
transmet habituellement par les mains
donc c'est important de ne pas toucher
les yeux le nez ou encore la bouche on
regarde aussi et religieusement le point
de presse à 13h du premier ministre
françois legault en famille l'annulation
du règlement du ministère est assisté en
fait de l'anxiété chez eux au début avec
l'annnonce du fait que les examens du
ministère aurait pas lieu cette année
ça a été très rassurant le pour eux mais
omis elle se demande ce que fera le
gouvernement du québec pour mettre fin à
la crise
à ces inquiétudes est-ce qu'ils vont
tout de suite pensé à faire un vaccin 1
ouais ils vont uniquement se préoccuper
sur autre chose que le vaccin qui
pourrait tous nous sauver
mettre fin à la crise il lui permettre
de retrouver ses amis ceux avec qui elle
jouait auparavant dans ses ruelles
ici jean philippe revient réseau canada
montréal